hey guys what's up this is andrew from
chainsenses.com so in this video guys i
want to make an update on what is
happening on the global market because
you guys know that it's all related to
what we can see happening in the meme
stocks as well so i want to make a big
analysis on the s p 500 tracker spy and
triple q let's get into it
[Music]
alright guys so we're gonna use the tool
that is working the best to analyze the
spy the global market the s p 500
tracker it's elliot wave counting guys
so we are going here try to find the
best counseling and
try to predict where we are in terms of
wage development so
we are starting at the end of the covet
crisis guys in march 20 two years ago
almost one year and three quarters
so we had first a massive rebound guys
okay starting from here and of course
this rebound was happening in uh five
waves one two three four five all right
then we had a correction that last two
months abc easy so we did one we did two
now it's gonna become a little bit more
tricky
so uh bam bam bam
i have two counting so you so this is my
uh best counting guys
it's the one that is making the most
sense to me then we start a new massive
move up right and to me it happened like
that one two three four five okay you
can see guys each time uh the elliott
wave theory relies on the fact that you
need to find the counting that is
fitting the best guys okay and this
counting that i'm having
here is fitting very well because motif
waves develop in five waves which each
time the third wave being the most
impulsive one one two three four five
then here i can do the exact same thing
guys one two three four five and then
four and one two three four five so you
can see this counting is fitting
extremely well all right i won't do the
same thing here but i could one two
three four five one two three four five
all right so we have a counting that is
verifying all the elliot wave rules and
that is giving us the top at 480 being
the top of the third wave only so we are
heading for a false wave and i told you
guys for those who are with me on
discord i'm talking about this reversal
since we are end of december because
we're having the signals after reversal
the signals of a reversal is when you
have the momentum going lower with the
price action making higher highs it's a
bearish divergence this is not always
signaling a reversal but most of the
time it is so just you need to be to pay
attention to those momentum information
so here then we have the breakout all
right guys so now the question we have
so we are correcting right so what are
we correcting in this scenario we are
correcting the third wave so first let's
try to give some targets for the third
wave correction so you guys know that
you apply fields to only the third wave
because this is what we are correcting
and we check the ratio so the 38.2 is at
420 so we have already reached that so
this is
telling me that maybe we have already
reached uh the deep i mean the lowest
level of this correction if we didn't
then we might go to the 50 or 61.8
percent retracement level which are at
400 and 380 all right so keep those
levels in mind 400 380. then we let's
put some support levels on the downside
so once again i check the previous lows
guys this is how it's working this is
where you have liquidity where you have
super buyers waiting so here we had one
at 427 i keep it even if it was a bit we
went through but came back quickly
next one is at 415 and 405 right so
those are the support levels that we
might uh go to in the a wave and we know
that 400 is the 50 retracement level so
400 is a double level so it makes sense
for the end of this correction now uh
those corrections they usually happen in
three ways a b c so
we have many scenarios guys so the first
and most likely scenario is that we are
in the a wave so i'm not sure the a wave
is complete or not all right we are
below the 200-day moving average so this
is bearish bears and control uh we had a
very bullish uh close on friday up 2.5
uh we but we closed above 40 uh 440
which was a level uh an important level
important support uh resistance level
but we're below the 200-day moving
average so i don't know
who is actually going to be leading on
monday but if you have a bullish happen
and a bullish day on monday and we close
above the 200-day moving average and the
440 level so let's say around four four
three then most likely guys we're gonna
have a bullish week so this is gonna
impact all the other stocks as well amc
gme included so uh we're gonna be
watching that very carefully then in
this case let's say we have a bullish
open because this is what we're
interested to know what will what can
happen next week then probably we would
go to the
450 or maybe even the 460 level so i
don't know for 450 460 the 50 460 level
is the breakout level so it's an
important level to watch guys there's
going to be a lot of sellers waiting
there so if we go there quickly it would
be rejected for like
80 ninety percent of uh probability the
first time and i don't know how deep
guys i'm not saying it's an easy trade
i'm just telling you that there is a
strong resistance at 460. uh so
let's see uh let's see if we're able to
go to those levels if we do then we once
again have two scenarios ah either uh we
are doing a b wave this is the most
likely scenario so so sorry this was a b
wave so we do something like that and
then we have a c wave coming to the 400
level yes so be prepared for that uh
it's very likely that we see another leg
down on the snp 500 even if we have a
rebound the alternative scenario that is
bearish is that we just go lower right
away guys and we uh come back to those
supports 415 400 or five so i think it's
a good idea to start to buy the dip on
some big chips like apple amazon google
you know all those big companies because
they're gonna react very very positively
if we have a strong rebound on the s p
500 so this is what i'm personally going
to be doing i'm going to be buying those
stocks around those levels okay so yeah
alternatives now we go lower then we
have the b wave and then if we go over
here guys maybe it's going to be the end
of the correction all right if we go
lower right away maybe the abc is like
that okay so i don't know it's too early
to say so we're gonna need to know
if so basically the question we're
having is we're gonna have a rebound
sooner or later either we go lower and
then rebound or rebound right away so
the question we're having is is it a b
wave starting or is it uh a first wave
starting so to answer that question we
need to check the difference between a b
wave which is a corrective wave and a
first wave which is an impulsive wave a
motive wave where values are very strong
so to answer that question we're gonna
check in the past how it's usually
happening guys and here we have an
example we have a b wave and after we
have the first wave okay b wave a b c
first wave one two three four five and
let's check the differences between
those two so first here i added the
volume you can see the volume involved
in the b wave are lower than the volume
involved in the first wave so first
we're going to check if the volume on
the s p 500 on the spy is very high or
not in this rebound wave if it is it
means that all buyers want to get back
it means the sen the bullish sentiment
is really bad guys so this is going to
be a very good news for the global
market if we see that
we also gonna need to see a very strong
moves up guys look here it was gap up
gap up gap up each time it was plus two
plus two
and plus two the sp y in october 20
did three consecutive sessions of plus
two percent opening each time with the
gap up okay we evolving high volume so
if we see that we can already use this
information to say that we are probably
in the first wave and if we are in the
first wave it means the correction is
done okay this is unfortunately not my
preferred scenario but i'm giving you
the scenario
and bam bam bam and then we'll probably
go to the 600 level all right around
july maybe uh you know maybe a little
bit later to know where the fifth wave
might go guys we measure we apply fibs
guys it's working very well we apply
fibs here to one plus three bottom of
the force okay so we don't know exactly
where the bottom of the force would be
and the 61.8 percent retracement flip
projection for the global market for
very impulsive stocks you can go as as
high as the 1.618 but the 0.618 is the
most likely one for uh the spy
especially after having one plus three
so extended so probably uh 580 all right
something like that maybe in august
something like this guys okay so this is
the very bullish case unfortunately it's
not my preferred scenario like i said
guys my preference now is that we have
an abc okay something like that
so
be careful guys this b wave is going to
be very tricky you're gonna uh i mean
it's not i think the right time to buy
uh once again we can compare the
situation as to what happened in 2016
because in 2016 we had a rate hike as
well after a very strong bull market
here between 2012 and 215 guys rates
were going lower we had a massive
quantitative easing just like we have
right now i mean the one we have we had
in 22 21 was much much bigger uh but
then we can compare and look at that
correction guys so that correction
happened exactly the same way so
the first rate hike occurred in november
15 and you can see the market started to
drop uh roughly six months before guys
uh sorry three months before so uh the
first rate hike is gonna happen in march
so we are right now three months before
so we are basically here guys okay we
are here so what
might very well happen and you can see
we have this trendline it was exactly
the same situation the bearish
divergence here guys this situation was
exactly the same that the one we're
having right now okay so what we can
expect just look at the past and we need
to assume the same causes will create
the same consequences so we probably
gonna have a b wave guys that's gonna be
tricky guys because if you were here in
this train look
[Music]
at that time you would feel like oh we
have
so i think we're here so we're gonna
maybe have a bounce maybe do an abc even
like that all right guys look at this
abc
okay and then you think here we have a
rebound you think that we are getting
bullish again but guys this was a trap
all right and then bam the market just
dropped heavily okay so what i mean is
that it took six months into 15 to 16.
right now it's been only two months and
i think we are we we might have the
first bounce of this correction but this
correction would probably happen guys
exactly like it's happening uh all the
time doing some abcs everywhere so you
know maybe an abc like this
then an abc like that
and finally one like that okay so we
might have something like this with a
lot of ups and downs with some fake outs
on the upside fake outs on the damp side
so it's not going to be easy to check
yes so just be prepared for that
don't buy high by buy low gas this is
the environment where buying breakouts
on the upside is not good i love to buy
breakouts but i won't be doing it here i
would rather try to buy the dip and try
to take profits early so now triple q
guys i won't be doing the same analysis
again i'm just going to give you the
equivalent levels so we are in the same
situation guys we broke out below 370.
so and right now we are just below the
resistance level at 352. so if we close
above 3 52 on monday we're probably
gonna have a bullish week bullish week
that might go to the 365 370 level where
we might see a another leg down taking
place and last thing guys you need to be
also prepared for the fact that uh maybe
this counting i told you it's the best
counting you can have right now but you
guys know that countings of when you use
elliot to a theory and you apply
counties it's very subjective and this
is to me fitting very well i mean if one
of you guys find something better come
to this code show me what you have but
this is the best content i can find but
let's assume that i'm wrong here guys
that this is like that okay that we have
a first very shallow first wave
and that the fifth wave was here that
this is the third okay it's possible
guys look i did another counting
that is fitting not as good but at least
fitting as well and this would mean that
we are correcting the entire move up
guys that started in march not only the
third wave so now we'll apply fibs here
and we would at least go to the 38.2
percent of this uh move up because
correction needs to go to the 38.2
to be considered as corrections so then
it would give us a level of 380 on the
spy that we probably would reach in june
or may you know april something like
that yes so just those are the levels so
380 400 415 so anything below 400 is a
massive buy to me especially if it
happens in the a wave so that we can
take profits in the b wave guys then 460
470 is a selling area guys this is an
area where i mean i would be personally
taking profits and then we will probably
have a massive another leg down and
again reloading at 380 guys would be if
we have the opportunity to do that a
beautiful beautiful trade because then
we would have another bullish cycle that
would be starting so that's it for me
guys i hope you enjoyed this video and
if you did please don't forget to click
on the sub like and bell button so
you're going to be the first to know
when i upload anything new and stay
close to shore see you guys